Otra vez tenemos tres objetos desconocidos
y queremos saber su valor y lo que podemos observar,
es que la masa total de estos tres
objetos desconocidos es igual a la masa de
estos 9 objetos que están de este lado,
que son de 1 kilogramo.
Así que de este lado tenemos 9 kilogramos
y de este lado tenemos tres objetos desconocidos,
pero de igual masa y les llamaremos "x".
Esta vez me gustaría que abordáramos la
situación desde un punto de vista matemático.
En otra ocasión ya habíamos hecho un ejercicio
y en el cual diríamos, para conservar el equilibrio
¿qué tal si dividimos por 1/3 ambos lados?
y conservaremos el equilibrio.
Esto es la masa total de este lado es igual
a la masa total de este lado, pero tratemos
de hacerlo de una manera simbólica,
esto es, podremos establecer una ecuación que
relacione a estas tres masas que llamamos "x"
y que su masa total sea igual a la masa
total de este lado.
Te daré unos segundos para ver si puedes hacerlo.
Veamos que tenemos aquí, de este lado tenemos
tres objetos cuya masa total es 3 veces "x",
que lo podemos escribir como "x" más "x"
más "x".
De este lado tengo 1 más 1 más 1, que son
3, más 1, más, más 1, más 1...
a ver ¿cuántos llevo?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 y 9
y lo que hemos hecho es una expresión algebraica
válida y podríamos ahora verla con más
cuidado y decir, si tengo "3x" o sea, una
"x", más otra "x", más otra "x", entonces
lo escribo como "3x" y esto es igual...
y de este lado de acá sumo todos los 1,
uno más uno más...
todos los que sean y son 9,
así que es igual a 9 y a ver, vamos a verificar,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Y ahora, podríamos preguntarnos, ¿qué podemos
hacer matemáticamente...?
O sea, observemos esta ecuación que tenemos aquí,
¿qué podríamos hacer matemáticamente para saber el valor de nuestra "x" misteriosa?
Trata de pensarlo por unos segundos.
Bueno y lo que hemos estado haciendo en estos
ejercicios es, bueno, vamos a observar a nuestra
balanza que está en equilibrio y lo que yo
haga de un lado, lo tendré que hacer del
otro lado para conservar el equilibrio.
Y se nos podría ocurrir, bueno, vamos a quitar
"2x" de ambos lados y vamos a hacerlo aquí
algebraicamente, pero no va a funcionar,
entonces "3x" menos "2x" va a ser igual a 9 menos "2x". Y entonces nos quedará, "3x" menos "2x"
es iguala una "x" y de este lado nos quedará
9 menos "2x", entonces todavía de este lado
tenemos nuestra "x" misteriosa...
y esto pues ya vimos no funciona,
pero recordemos nuestro otro ejercicio,
¿qué pasa si tomamos 1/3 de lo que está de este lado y 1/3 de lo que está de este lado?
Conservaríamos el equilibrio y matemáticamente
sería equivalente a decir, vamos a multiplicar
ambos lados por 1/3, otra forma de decirlo
es que vamos a dividir ambos lados entre 3.
Multiplicar por 1/3 es lo mismo que dividir entre 3,
si multiplicamos ambos lados por 1/3...
por ejemplo, aquí visualmente multiplicar por 1/3,
solo nos va a quedar una "x", entonces
multiplicamos ambos lados por 1/3
y de este lado que tengo 9 kilogramos, si multiplico
por 1/3, solo me quedarán 3 kilogramos.
Y también lo podríamos ver aquí, si multiplicamos
por 1/3, como lo estoy indicando,
entonces me va a quedar que "x" es igual a 1 más 1
más 1, que es igual a 3.
Y acá, hagamos las operaciones, si yo multiplico
1/3 por 3 me queda 1, o sea que entonces nada
más tengo una "x" y de este lado, si multiplico
1/3 por 9, me queda 9/3 que es 3,
lo que es igual a 3.
Y llegamos al resultado.